- [Voiceover] How many dogs do you see?
And I have the dogs down here,
we just need to count them.
So, if I'm starting with this dog,
and I wanna make sure that
I don't count him again,
so I wanna remember, I'm
starting with this top dog.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
I see eight dogs.
You might be tempted to go, nine.
But I already counted this dog.
So there's only eight dogs.
So I see eight dogs.
So let's check our answer.
Got it right.
How many mice do you see?
Same thing, I like to
start with the top mouse,
but we have to remember,
if I'm gonna start counting
with the top mouse,
I don't wanna keep counting the top mouse.
So one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
Now, you might be tempted to go
eight, but we already
counted this top mouse.
So there's only seven mice here.
Seven mice.
You gotta be careful not to keep going
in circles and counting the mice
over and over and over again.
You only wanna count
each of the mice once.
Let's do another one.
This is too much fun.
How many cookies do you see?
All right, they're all jumbled up here,
and we just have to be careful
not to count the cookie twice.
So let's see, one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine.
There are nine cookies.
I see nine cookies.
How many mice are there?
Okay, now, here there are a lot of mice.
So there's one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10, 11,
12, 13, 14, 15, 16,
17, 18 19 mice.
There are 19 mice there.
That's a lot of mice.